Come on,
rain d 3-book dictionary
8 I played the
piano when I was little and was
exposed to music, so
from there
I became more and more fond of sweets
and made my debut.
In particular, my father was good at following, and
he often sang melancholy songs, so
for example, my name Eliza
came from my dear Ellie
, and I played songs on the cello that weren't too bright.  My
father was the kind of person who would do things like that, so
I think that kind of unfamiliar trait was probably influenced by 7.
My father and mother decided to use the name rape before it became popular overseas, so the
name was changed to Rape.  That's right, a
very beautiful name
, look at the research
Version 4
fav I can't do it right now The Irregular at Funk High School Right now
.  It
really felt like I wasn't one of them,
but I was able to
sing.I wasn't nervous at all.  So I thought about what to say in English and what to say on
this mc day,
but it was also a natural island,
and it ended up being a bit sluggish,
but everyone was happy to have a climbing dog
.
I was a housewife, so I thought what would I do if I was a child every day,
but
I'm a sunny girl, so
I do
n't think I've been able to sleep so far.
I thought
white is a lot of alcohol in a row,
but
cheese is cheap
I thought Japan was really good
Hi m 1
Happy transportation I can't get a
road connection
No
I can't speak English yet but I
'm fluent again
I hope I can send my singing voice to everyone when
I go home.I will do my best in Japan, so
please support
me.